we've seen you go through your fair
share of relationships in the spotlight
where are things with you and nick now
are you completely done
you know nick is in my day-to-day life
right now really
i have just chosen to keep that part of
my
life a little bit more private because i
saw that the more i
introduced the world into it the more
issues
and the more opinion yeah the more
issues and just the more opinions that
came my way
and i feel like i'm gonna point my life
right now to where
i am i'm 24 years old and one of my best
friends
i remember having a conversation with
her and she was like savannah you're
going to be a completely different
person
at 24 than you are 27
and that you are at 30. she was like
just take your time
you're a different person from week to
week i know right
your brother so i think i'm just in a
phase in my life to where
i'm figuring out who i am as a person
and i've got
my cosmetic line sassy by savannah
that's launched and
i'm continuing to grow that coming out
with hair accessories and blow dryers
and
there's so many different projects going
on in my life right now then i'm like
everything can kind of move at snail's
pace yeah i'm
i want to make sure that like dad said
when you get married
it's forever i don't want to bring a
child into this world
and have that child suffer the
consequences of me being immature and
wanting to
get married just because i think it's
the cool thing to do so
i want to make sure that i'm mature
enough to take that next step
and the person that i'm with is mature
enough to take that next step
and i don't feel like you should treat
people like they're disposable either
and that's been the biggest thing with
nick is there's so many things that we
don't
agree on but then there's so many things
we do agree on and
just because you disagree with someone
doesn't mean you throw them away
so are you and nick dating we yes
okay so we are exclusively yes
okay and and snell's pace is good sassy
savannah is on the move
she's doing her thing that's okay
you know we're actually proud of
you know our children seeing these
things and saying okay
we need to pump the brakes the wedding
is off and so is the engagement
when savannah came to us and said i'm
not ready to move forward with this
wedding
um she was devastated to tell
us that and i said honey don't you worry
about it were you afraid that you were
disappointing them or
i think there was a little bit of that
but the and there was also i think it
more so it was
my insecurities and feeling like i have
failed this relationship
and it's really hard having a
relationship in the spotlight
and also with the person that i'm with
is not used to this life either
and it's been really hard on him as well
i want to make sure
that when that day comes and i walk down
an aisle i know without a
doubt that it's forever yeah because i'm
only paying for it once
i know so i don't make the most of it i
think you're
stunning i think you're sweet you are
everything that julie and i have dreamed
of
okay you remember our deal you said you
weren't gonna be extra and the
dial is kind of turning i'm on one why
need to be on zero
what about miss emmy
what about her is she still in the
picture uh you know
emmy and i we've kind of we went through
a rough patch and we decided to go our
separate ways
did you yeah i'm sorry because i felt
like we
we i feel like we see you shopping for
engagement rings this season yeah
you've seen me do a lot of foolish stuff
it's nothing new that you haven't seen
for nine seasons but you know what it's
what they have to go through
so are you single ready to mingle or are
you i'm single
you're single ladies chase is available
hit him up on the idea trust me you
don't have to make that announcement oh
i'm sure he makes it very well known
what are y'all doing
none of your business people leave their
kids
all the time let's be those parents
congrats to the whole family on
season nine chrisley knows best then
we've got season three
of growing up chrisley in one word
describe what it means to be a part of
the chrisley family
love yeah just blessed what would you
say todd
very fortunate okay and what about you
sure chaotic yes
yes the queen has spoken mama keeping it
related
yes the two of you think that you would
be on this journey of reality tv for as
long as you have
not at all i think i heard dad say
earlier
we all thought if we just got past
season two then
all right we're good yeah this was a
great accomplishment
but now we're in season nine and it's
hard to believe
we're the chrisleys todd in julie
chrisley we live in a neighborhood
north of atlanta i mean we have
literally seen
the siblings the two of you grayson
chloe as well all grown before
our eyes chloe she is just precious as
can be
she's the boss she truly is just be very
clear you're 52
now why did you have to teach your math
and girlfriend can roll them eyes or
kind of give you a look
like her looks she has that chrisley
we call it chrisley two she has that
chrisley attitude
we have five children our oldest
daughter is lindsay lindsay is beautiful
she's smart she's [ __ ]
the two of you are two of five children
and so sadly we don't see a lot of
lindsay we don't
see anything of lindsay anymore in the
show
kyle your dad reconnected with him
reconciled with him last year
you know that i cannot welcome you back
into our family until i know that you're
where you need to be
yeah i want my family back
and i'll do whatever it takes in order
to make that happen
what does your relationship look like
with lindsay and kyle today
chase and savannah i love to see when
anyone
is doing well because never do i want to
wish
anything bad upon anyone especially my
siblings if they ever needed anything
i'm here for it it's just everyone's
kind of on a different path right now
are you in communication with him at all
no no
no what about you chase um i've talked
to kyle a little bit
and i mean i'm proud of where he is
today um he's definitely went through it
and he's come out on the other side
so i'm proud of him for that i'm here if
he ever needs anything i'm here for
lindsay if she ever needs anything
for anything that lindsay or kyle has
done
you know i forgive you because for you
to have done what you did
you just had to have been in a really
crappy place in life
so for that i forgive them and you know
god's
got a purpose and a plan and
at the end of the day everyone you you
come back
whether it's here on earth or in heaven
we're all going to come back as a whole
from our family do we forgive lindsay
lindsay's forgiven
will we ever forget it probably not
will it ever be the way that i've
envisioned
in my life that it would be um
i don't know so it sounds like things
probably will never be the same
i don't know how they could ever be the
same i have watched her
go out here and and and make these false
misrepresentations
um to the press um and and it was funny
to her
you know this was this was something
that was gaining her notoriety it was
getting her name in the press
it was watching her numbers grow on
social media
um that's what this was all about on
happier times though
these two celebrating 25 years of wedded
bliss for the most part right
bliss baby bliss uh savannah chase what
do you think is the secret
to these two being successfully married
for 25 years
i think they just i mean they they
support each other my mom's got his back
and he's definitely got hers i mean
loyalty loyalty and they love each other
unconditionally yeah
and i think especially in today's day
and age especially with social media
and tv it's
relationships are hard but for them i've
seen them
turn into each other instead of turning
to other sources
and that's the only way to stay close is
to
lean on each other and they've set a
perfect example of
what we want and what is a healthy
relationship
very sweet very sweet
you